des fraudes au chômage partiel c'est ce
que dénoncent plusieurs salariés en
france dans les colonnes du quotidien le
monde plusieurs salariés témoignent plus
de huit millions de salariés ont été
placés en chômage partiel depuis début
du confinement et certains dénoncent
l'attitude de leur employeur ils sont
ainsi nombreux à avoir travaillé alors
que les conditions du chômage partiel
mais les autorise pas bien évidemment
beaucoup en ont gardé les preuves et
s'estime aujourd'hui les et on en parle
tout de suite avec lucien flamand il est
avocat en droit du travail et en droit
social
monsieur vraiment bonjour merci d'être
avec nous alors est-ce que c'est illégal
d'avoir demandé à des salariés mis au
chômage partiel de continuer à
travailler
oui tout à fait alors je pense qu'on
peut sans doute distinguer différents
types de situation il ya la première
situation à laquelle on a mis les
salariés au chômage partiel total
et puis en fait on continue à leur
demander de travailler quasiment à plein
temps alors ça c'est évidemment illégal
c'est une infraction pénale c'est une
une infraction de fausses déclarations
vis-à-vis l'administration et c'est
aussi du du travail dissimulé donc on a
des sanctions pénales qui sont des
peines de plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'euros d'amendé de plusieurs années
d'emprisonnement
et il ya toute une série d'autres
d'autres sanctions les salariés peuvent
obtenir une indemnisation spécifique il
peut y avoir des majorations de la part
de l'urssaf sur les cotisations ça c'est
que voilà ça c'est un premier cas de
figure je pense qu'il peut y avoir un
deuxième cas de figure dans lequel on
allie les salariés par exemple à 50%
et puis il peut y avoir des débats
l'employeur jusqu'où ils ont jamais
dépassé les 50% et puis parfois les
salariés je trouve que l'iso travailler
un petit peu plus que 50 %
voilà les choses sont moins en moins
évidente
et c'est aussi un peu le propre de de
l'organisation en télétravail cinq ans
les salariés viennent dans les bureaux
il ya des jours où des demi journées
travaillées c'est très facile de savoir
quel jour ont été travaillés quelques
jours n'ont pas été travaillée alors
quand on est chez soi en télétravail
bon ben voilà est-ce que le fait de
prendre un coup de fil dans la journée
ça équivaut à un travail sur toute
l'après midi
il peut y avoir beaucoup plus de
beaucoup plus de débats alors comment
l'inspection du travail peut-être décelé
ce genre de fraude alors pour le moment
c'est vrai que ce n'est pas évident pour
me faire des contrôles chez les chez les
salariés je pense que ça peut être
beaucoup des salariés qui vont qui
peuvent dénoncer la situation inspection
du travail et dire en particulier ceux
qui étaient en chômage partiel total qui
écoute et qui consiste à dire écoutez
moi on m'a mis en chômage partiel total
enfin regardez j'ai traité des mails
j'ai passé des appels skype etc
évidemment tout ça laisse une trace et
c'est peut-être sur ces éléments là que
pourront se pourra se baser
l'administration pour sanctionner pour
réprimer alors un salarié justement qui
va signaler ce genre de fraude de quelle
manière il est protégé et alors
évidemment tout tout tout dépend le
signalement de cette fraude sera pas
sera pas nécessairement pour être pour
être anonyme éventuellement ça c'est
toujours ça c'est toujours possible
après c'est plus une question pratique
et on peut penser que l'inspection du
travail va pas non plus forcément
indiqué des des noms en particulier
après on est dans le cadre des règles de
droit commun de 2,3 du travail
évidemment l'employeur ne peut pas
licencier un salarié au motif qu'il
devrait dénoncer une infraction dans le
dans l'entreprise est ce que à l'heure
actuelle alors vous parlez ce qu'il ya
des travailleurs nés salariés qui
etc ont pris contact avec vous pour
dénoncer ce genre de fraude
non moi je n'ai pas eu de j'ai pas eu de
dossier en ce sens pour le moment
voilà moi les situations que j'ai vu
tout le monde a joué tout le monde a
joué le jeu et puis même cette question
du chômage partiel à 50 % de ce que j'ai
pu voir ça se fait en bonne en bonne
intelligence avec avec l'employeur de ce
que j'ai pu voir après ça que parfois il
peut y avoir des situations où les
employeurs ont pu hésiter se poser la
question ce salarié est ce que c'est un
arrêt de travail pour garder les enfants
est ce que j'ai un chômage partiel il ya
aussi voilà parfois des interrogations
qui ont pu avoir lieu et des maladresses
ont pu être qui ont pu être commises
sachant qu'il ya eu quand même un
certain vu le flux de dossiers qui a dû
gérer l'administration sur les premières
semaines de mise en place c'est vrai que
les réponses de l'administration et
modalités déclaratives et sont en place
progressivement
donc on n'avait pas forcément au début
pour les employeurs toutes les réponses
aux questions
merci monsieur flamande avoir été avec
nous en direct
l'appel que vous êtes avocat en droit du
travail en droit social merci